he may have dazzled audiences a sparkly
vampire Edward Cullen but behind the
scenes Robert Pattinson had a dirty
little secret here's the gross habit
that could make fans see him in a whole
new light the Twilight Saga has
everything you could possibly want in a
teen romance star-crossed lovers a
shockingly good soundtrack and a creepy
telepathic baby and instead of sleeping
in Dusty old coffins these vampires are
glimmering Immortals beautiful beyond
compare however Bella Swan still has a
hard time choosing between the
mysterious Edward Cullen and the Moody
werewolf Jacob Black it seems like it
would be a pretty easy decision
especially because Edward and the other
vampires constantly remarked that Jacob
and the werewolves carry a foul stem to
them wherever they go but apparently the
situation is reversed in real life
drawing a 2012 interview with extra
Pattinson was asked to address a comment
he made about not washing his hair for
six weeks and his answer would send
every sense sensitive vampire running
for the hills why don't we see the point
in washing her hair like unless to be
clean maybe but I mean but like if you
don't care if your hair's clean or not
then why would you wash it Pattinson
then compared his unwashed hair to its
untidy living space saying it's like I
don't clean my apartment because I don't
care I have my apartment for sleeping in
and I have my hair for just you know
hanging out on my head I don't care if
it's clean or not it could be hard to be
objective about your own cleanliness but
it's impossible to know the truth when
other sources have made conflicting
comments about Pattinson's hygiene the
vampires in Twilight don't sweat so
readers might like to imagine that
Edward smells like the pages of the
books in his bedroom and the crisp
Forest air after climbing all those
trees of Bella unfortunately One Source
says that Pattinson smelled badly enough
on set that it affected his co-workers
an anonymous crew member who worked
closely with Pattinson during the
production of New Moon told E news he
stinks I mean it's awful he never
showers and it drives people on the set
crazy he completely reeks knowing that
patinson himself said that he doesn't
have the best hygiene habits sucks the
romance out of all those scenes where
Edward and Bella get up in each other's
personal space however his co-star has
her own opinion on the subject Kristen
Stewart told people before the first
film at theaters in November 2008 he
smells great it's kind of an animalist
thing that goes on it went along with
the movies so it was perfect Pattinson
has notoriously marked the Twilight
franchise over the years so he clearly
has a sense of humor his comments about
hygiene could be true or just another
self-deprecating joke either way
Pattinson apparently made some
improvements to a self-care routine
after the Twilight franchise wrapped in
2013 it was announced that the actor
would become the face of Dior arm
fragrance which the company describes as
having an alluring earthy scent surely a
luxury brand like the house of Dior
wooden tab patterns done for the job if
they didn't think his image could sell
cologne though the actor amidst a
partnering with the company may have in
fact improved his skin care regimen
Pattinson explained to the Wall Street
Journal in 2014 I was a brush your teeth
and have a shower kind of guy I can't
tell if it's because of my association
with Dior or because I'm older but I've
started moisturizing it's been a quite
profound change in my life I like my
smile an anonymous sourceman movies set
more than a decade ago hardly counts as
evidence still Pattinson's apparent
disregard for Hygiene may surprise them
as a Twilight Saga gears up to return as
a TV series fans May wonder whether they
prefer the new Edward or the allegedly
foul smelling original
foreign